Влад вчиться ходити заново. Він втратив ногу під час боїв за "Азовсталь".
Що складно? Сходи. А, і мокра погода.
По мені влучили з авіації. Було попередження по рації, що буде авіаобстріл, усім в укриття.
А хлопці з мого взводу, мої побратими були на позиціях, а не в укритті.
Я прийшов в укриття відпочити, а коли почув цей сигнал, побіг до них, щоб доповісти. Я навіть не встиг…
Я почав тікати, по нам почала працювати авіація, по мені влучили.
Вибратися з Маріуполя до Запоріжжя хлопцю допомогли місцеві. Росіянам на блокпостах вони сказали, що Влад - поранений цивільний.
Хоча татуювання на його тілі свідчать, що він боєць батальйону "Азов".
Мене закутали, виходить. Ногу теж замотали, вона вся в крові була. Я весь у бинтах був.
І росіяни не лізли дивитися. Вони дивляться - є кров, чувак взагалі без ноги лежить, в напівсвідомості.
Влад на військовій службі з 17 років. Сам родом з Донецька. У 2014 році з батьками перебрався до Маріуполя.
Служив у добровольчому батальйоні "Донбас", потім - у морській прикордонслужбі.
Донецьк - мій дім. Через це я хотів воювати - за Донецьк, щоб повернути його в Україну, бо я не збираюся повертатися туди, поки там є Росія.
Там жили мої предки, вони померли на цій землі. Це моя земля.
Ми козаки, у нас свої правила, розумієте? Ми живемо своїм життям, ми хоч і дуже різні, але однакові.
Ми з самого початку були добрим народом. Нам же теж не подобається воювати.
Я би хотів спокійно жити в країні, яка добре розвивається і яку ніхто не чіпає.
Згодом хлопець вступив до полку "Азов". Влад розповідає, що це було життя, про яке він мріяв.
Підрозділ став його родиною. Він тренувався з шостої ранку до самого вечора: біг, стрільба, тренажерний зал, медицина.
Цілими днями у нас була підготовка, підготовка, підготовка.
І ти живеш у такому мікросвіті, де немає алкоголіків, наркоманів, немає грубості, усі з тобою вітаються.
Це такий світ у світі. Я навіть коли хворів, я ходив сам у зал і займався. Я розумів, що з потом вийде ця хвороба.
Я навіть так скажу: у мене була відпустка, я жив на базі у відпустці цілий місяць, ходив на тренування, на лекції, ходив на тактику.
І все одно я прокидався о шостій ранку і займався так само, як і в робочий час. Настільки це ідеальна система була.
Нині, після поранення й кількох місяців у лікарнях, він дуже схуд. Протезист поки що невдоволений Владовим прогресом.
Ти жахливо ходиш. Мені всі говорили, що ти тут майже літаєш, красунчик. А ти паскудно ходиш. Як крива качка.
Поки Влад втрачає вагу, лікарям треба коригувати розміри протезу. Протезисти нині на вагу золота. До цієї клініки з лютого невпинно надходять пацієнти.
Зараз схудла культя, стабілізуємо розміри протезу, щоб було все щільно.
Уже тиждень-два і, я вважаю, зробимо постійний протез, і вже буде ганяти нормально.
Після трьох років в "Азові" Влад поволі звикає до нової ноги й до цивільного життя.
Люди почали жити, таке відчуття, наче немає війни. Вони живуть у своєму світі: дім-робота, дім-робота, поїдемо шашлички посмажимо, дім-робота-шашлички.
І все. П'ють. Вони живуть своїм життям, як жили до війни. Їм просто треба дати прочуханки, аби вони зрозуміли, що тут війна.
Влад зізнається, що мало стежить за новинами. Хлопцеві боляче, що його побратими з "Азова" досі в Росії, під ризиком страти.
Ми готові були померти там в Маріуполі. Кожен - хоч би в країні все було нормально.
Зеленський пообіцяв, обіцянку не виконав, обманув хлопців. Він дав наказ, каже - здавайтеся, ми вас обміняємо. Нічого не відбулося.
Через розчарування у керівництві держави Влад замислюється про виїзд за кордон.
Поки ж чим може допомагає побратимам з "Азова".
Плани на майбутнє будує разом з дружиною. Подружжя чекає на первістка.